chants right here shot clock is off
well it has a timeout
whether a chance to send the Thunder
home
Willard long-range three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a 37-foot dagger oh my goodness look at
that shot to put them out he went 450
that was forty seven forty eight nine
and fifty points on that was such
amazing
five years ago
hit a tree against
yes to win the first round series
[Applause]
for 50 points
goodnight Oklahoma City sees it over
Wow
I'm a jerk Terry Stotts all you can do
is just shake your head that was an
amazing shot on an amazing night of
shooting by Damian Lillard Oh Damian
Lillard makes ten three-pointers sets a
franchise playoff record as the new
playoff record with 50 points and the
most scintillating
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
five years ago
one of the biggest shots in franchise
history
[Applause]
[Music]
and history repeats itself five years
later
does it again bigshot taker bigshot
maker way more enjoyable watching it
than having it happen do I promise you
that Wow Dave time has arrived let's
send it to Stephanie all right thank you
so much Brian
[Applause]
the mentality of this
I mean the NBA teams going runs and
before you you know make your
breakthrough adversity is go ahead we
knew it you know we have been shooting
the ball well things started going our
way I knew eventually who's gonna have
to fight through something to come out
big and our team fought through you know
we made shots but what we was able to do
on the defensive end
with big stops mohit two big free throws
we did we made every play we needed to
make to to win this game see whether the
adversity you talked about it before
injuries to this team two times the
adversity in seasons past what has that
made you all into his weight as a more
mature subroutine
after last year I kept telling people
sometimes it's your turn to go through
something and when you keep fighting
then you keep working through it and
stay together it's a reward waiting for
you we kept working and I think this is
the beginning of our result you in
particular quite an offensive night
tonight what were you seeing that the
defense was giving you I mean they
weren't giving me anything
they were fighting for their lives you
know what type of game it was gonna be
and once I realized we didn't have it
going to start the game I knew I was
going to be more aggressive to start and
I was able to see some sass going guys
sprinted into screens
my execution or office
guys we won a few guys in the we side
class so I have room
things that allowed me to do the things
that I did tonight all right now the
education of this team you all watch a
lot of film you express that you have
patience going forward
dance in the playoffs what is the
biggest lesson that you can take away
moving forward I think the last two
times that we advanced I think we canto
is satisfied with getting out of the
first series sometimes the season wears
on you because someone's like you give
instead of fatigued in the Mitchell Park
I think we getting stung data later he
gets hit in sewing
Kevin I think that I slander they pour
it on him they pulled it right from his
veins you a lion and I loved everything
he said they made all the big plays down
this stretch they deserved it in this
game he was fantastic don't get me wrong
but defensively they came together his
shed okay see down the stretch they had
to make big plays they were coming from
behind they tied it up a small little
playability with 39 seconds to go
he takes it in he gives him a two for
one Ryan and that two for one
opportunity they came back old Cocina
okay sea mist led to that three so just
really good coaching my thoughts
fantastic execution by his team but a
wonderful game to watch tonight we just
witnessed a player in his prime with his
best game of his career 50 for Damian
Lillard and a 37 foot
to send Oklahoma City home for the
season
the Blazers advance out of the first
round for the third time in the last six
years for Hall of Famer Kevin McHale
Stephanie ready and our great crew led
by Jeff Randolph and Howie singer Brian
Anderson saying so long from Portland
let's send it to Ernie Johnson in our
Atlanta studios as delegate goes for
five old Blazers